the winner of the $1,000,000 and the
star of the headline show in Las Vegas
is congratulations
is that how you're feeling yes I have
nowhere it's just years I mean you were
overcome with emotion up there when they
announced her name why why the tears I
could just see all my friends and family
supporting me and crying with me and
just made me feel so overcome with joy
and tears lots of Tears a lot of love
coming your way isn't it yes and there
must be a surreal night because you also
have to share the stage with Terry Fator
you Terry and talking to Jeff they get
they give me so such good advice and I
really appreciate their advice what was
it like sharing that stage with Angelica
I mean two of the youngest contestants
first and second place that got to be
special joy I got to ask you how are you
going to spend that million dollar prize
to my mission program at church finally
going to be able to get her so mom watch
out for the dishwasher is that's what
you get out of washing dishes for her
[Music]
what are you gonna miss about this whole
experience Oh everything the people the
contestants everyone
and it's just been so much fun and I'm
so sad and so sad
[Music]
you